have you been that far down when you're
like I'm done with this I can't do it
anymore I I'm gonna move away I've had
those feelings where I just want to get
away were you ever that low what's
underneath the underneath is always
interesting to me you know it takes and
it's a little risky to do that because
you want to be liked and you want to get
from A to B to C and without having to
stop and explain or delve into certain
things I feel like you're complaining
all right moaning yeah I I had one
moment I was at I think I was at the
super Whole Foods the cashier casually
asked me how you doing and I said I'm
not so good wow and and she looked at me
and we looked at each other and I I
couldn't believe I said that but she
looked at me not with dismay or there
was a moment of connection that could
have gone on but we would have held up
the rest of the people she could have
even gone all right
I guess that's your theory